[Music]
Gary what do you got lined up today
right so we've had some questions and
one of them landed right in my backyard
it's how hard would you have to kick a
soccer ball or if you want football to
get it into orbit now yeah right people
are dreaming people dreaming superpowers
on this one aren't they just and that
just shows you just so as you understand
here on planet Earth the highest
recorded kick in the professional game
and this might surprise people
131 miles per hour
okay I didn't see that coming I didn't
see that one neither did the goalkeeper
and and
kill that no nobody
This Record seems like a bowling ball
knocked everybody down yeah no surprise
this is a Brazilian guy called Ronnie
heberson and he's he's done it a couple
of times he wasn't a one and done on
this uh this sort of speed so he's uh
he's got previous for it so it's a it's
interesting that the design of the new
balls has enabled them to travel faster
which is speeding the game up which is
exactly what everyone was after what I
wonder is
uh because I don't study soccer balls I
know it's a big deal you know before
every every World Cup but the the amount
that the ball compresses
so that when it's coming off your foot
there's not only the speed of your foot
that's translated to the ball there's
The Recoil of the ball off your toe yeah
for you having compressed it yes the def
the deformation and then the deformation
but it's not just a deferment because
you can deform something that doesn't
bounce back and then there's no good
right it's got It's got to have that
sort of that's the Tempur-Pedic ball yes
memory
it's a really slow game
very comfortable very comfortable slow
game it wraps your toes
exactly but no it's interesting because
you're now starting to roll this out
is it
an American football you want to kick
into orbit do you want to go away from
inflated balls and then get you know
what what's it going to take to get a
baseball into space a golf ball into
space you know where does your mind take
you as to the sort of projectile aspect
of it but I was surprised because I
didn't think the top speed of a soccer
ball would be anywhere near 130 miles
yeah neither did I plus when I played
little league and I have to think about
why this is true but I could always hit
a a spalding pink ball way farther than
a baseball and that's obviously an air
filled ball that re uh responds quickly
but I also unravel the baseball have you
ever done that maybe not not you Gary no
not lately yeah no American Truck have
you ever done that yeah by mistake I uh
I hit one so
you know I think they call it tearing
the camera
I think that's what they refer to it as
then you woke up and then what happened
this sounds an awful lot like a Robert
Redford movie yeah yeah I saw that movie
yeah right uh yeah so you so you
unstitch it and remove the leather and
then there's basically rubber bands that
are just it's a continuous sort of
rubber with like rubber bands and you
keep doing that and then there's this
like little yeah it's basically stringy
Rubber and then there's a little pink
ball but last I did this I don't know if
it's different today a little pink ball
and my pink ball had liquid in it and I
thought what what what's up with that
it's like the size of a marble a little
bigger than a marble a little mini
Planet
it is it's the it's the core
of the baseball yes okay so here's the
thing yeah so you want to know a cool
fact please it's a cool stupid geeky
fact all right
um the escape velocity for any object so
if for Earth it's it's a seven miles per
second okay okay
that's 31 miles per hour by the way
yeah so he ain't kicking in an orbit
yeah I was gonna say maybe Superman
could kick a ball that hard okay so
here's here's oh by the way so it's not
a matter of strength okay it's a matter
of speed of your foot so Superman is
strong but is he fast now you can catch
a speeding bullet he can catch a bullet
exactly that's pretty fast okay he's not
just he's not flash fast but he's no no
he's not right probably the second thing
after flash fast and he has super super
everything that's human which we once
discussed Chuck we discussed his
flatulence that he just concluded he
must also have super flatulence I have
to dig that one out of our archives
that's on that's on YouTube yeah it's a
super super flatulence by the way he's
not he wouldn't be the only one no no no
okay so now that I'm bragging here's an
interesting fact so you take the escape
velocity for a planet okay yeah and
divide it by the square root of two
and that's the speed you need to get
into orbit
oh
it's kind of a cool fact so okay okay so
uh so what is seven divided by square
root of two I'll do that right now
seven divided by
square root of two you get five so the
space station and the space shuttle and
Elon Musk and all these folks orbit the
Earth at five miles per second
right so that's lower than the escape
Velocity obviously because you're still
in orbit but scale velocity and orbital
speed low orbital speed are precisely
related by that formula in fact the
derivation of that was on my general
exam for graduate school
oh wow you can derive how and why that's
true
straightforward but you have to know
that that's a thing all right and then
figure out how to anyhow 130 miles an
hour it ain't happening on Earth so when
was it gonna happen so I take my ball
and I go off off work okay and I'm you
know when when am I going to go to get
myself my jollies about kicking the boat
into space okay so so Mars is not going
to work okay okay you're not fast enough
for March you're not even fast enough
for Pluto how about okay especially my
dreams here Neil oh you're not fast
enough even for uh the largest asteroid
is Series in fact series is so large
c-e-r-e-s yes from the root of cereal
comes from that by the way
um series was the goddess uh Harvest I
think one of these Farm goddesses uh
series is so large as an asteroid that
its own gravity shaped it into a sphere
and after the Pluto debical what
happened there again are we no we're not
but round things too small to be planets
are called
um dwarf planets Pluto got demoted from
planet to dwarf planet status and Ceres
which was in the ranks of asteroids got
promoted from asteroid to dwarf planet
right so on Pluto and Ceres the escape
Velocity is about
what do we get about a third
of a mile an hour
I can do that no no sorry sorry mile per
second excuse me third of a mile per
second yeah you ain't getting yeah
you're not happening right right so yeah
yeah these are big objects these are you
know they're they're they're hundreds of
miles across these objects okay yes uh
so the question is what size object can
we satisfy Gary's Superman urges
so let's look at big comets so Haley's
coming not as big as they come but it's
you know we've all heard of it and it's
visible and okay that one
uh it's like
half a mile an hour
oh really yeah yeah we could do that oh
no but then how are you going to play
the game at all oh no the comments like
some Chums I'm gonna get some Chums
we're gonna go up and we're gonna kick
balls from one asteroid to another oh oh
yeah just just don't chase after the
ball no it's been that extra it'd be
like golf you're gonna land it on
another rest oh okay okay but then you
okay so we can all run them up at least
one mile per hour so you if you run too
fast you can you can jump yourself into
orbit and to escape velocity so you're
right Gary you'd have to get a
configuration of asteroids and comets
and again all these are ten you know two
dozen miles across around there
um practically anything we throw as
humans or kick would would achieve
escape velocity so we need to wait for
one of those meatiest showers
we're going to get any joy out of that
uh why people say purses we can kill
none of the meter showers or tiny I like
the size of peas
no no no if excuse me excuse me the
comments we're talking about at 10 20
miles across the the the
the asteroid that took out the dinosaurs
yep was six miles across right yeah okay
you don't want these this is not what's
falling in a meteor shower yeah comets
Bruce Willis could help us exactly if
they were what were falling in a meteor
shower that's the end of all life on
Earth yeah
let's not do that let's not do that
right so uh yeah so but it made for one
hell of a soccer game
so going from a few dozen miles up to
like a few hundred miles is a very big
difference in escape velocity for us and
you're right Superman could do it at all
times oh and by the way that old adage
uh what goes up must come down
you know then grandma said that's only
true if what you throw up does not
achieve escape velocity
if it goes higher than seven miles per
second on Earth it will never come back
to earth wow it'll stay in the solar
system but it'll never come back to
earth
now if you wanted to leave the solar
system what you do is you say
what's Earth's speed
at our dis orbital speed at our distance
from the sun right okay if I take that
speed which is 30 kilometers a second
okay but 18 miles per second multiplied
by the square root of two I'll get the
escape Velocity from the Sun
at Earth's location ah so it works
beautifully this way
so if you want if you want to throw
something that not only never comes back
to Earth but just leaves the solar
system leaves the solar system you take
the 30 kilometer second multiply by
square root of 2 which is 1.4 so that's
it's like 400 it's like four what is it
um 30 uh 1.445
kilometers per second that comes out to
be about 30 miles per second so if you
get 30 miles per second like straight
out
it's gone you're gone you're gone so
we're gonna need that equation that's
mathematics when we when we decide that
we're gonna bug out of this particular
oh you have one system ago yeah of
course we have yeah
so that's like that's the only way I can
help you here Gary because it's cool
because it's it's
we are not physically able to achieve
this correct God thank God because if
you're the worst damn soccer game you've
ever seen you know everybody gets angry
and they kick it into orbit and it's
just there you go it's gone you go home
you go home and your father's sit and
they said well where's your ball well
John kicked it into space the bully the
soccer bully you go and get that ball
right now I haven't spent money just be
chaos oh here's an interesting fact yeah
um if
you okay if you don't achieve escape
velocity right the ball will want to
return to the spot where you kicked it
in an orbit
the problem is
Earth is in the way yes so if you shrunk
Earth down to a point
but you still floated up there and
kicked the ball and you didn't quite
achieve escape velocity it will make
this huge elongated orbit come around
and then hit you upside to back it a hit
but right now Earth is in the way it's
going to hit Earth on the other side of
the Earth so the interesting thing about
orbits the point you launch it is a
permanent spot of the orbital path of
the object itself basically
yes
suckering yeah and and an hour and a
half later it'll hit you right upside
the back of the head now that right
there is a Great Prank when you kick the
ball and then you just go
stand right there don't move
just wait just wait for it wait for it
bro
I Gary that's all the time we have here
I hope I helped you out there you did
thank you new okay excellent this has
been a star talk sports edition
explainer Neil deGrasse Tyson here as
always keep looking up
[Music]